ja aber es wird da sehen ist eine
hochstraße lage so gut für den täter als
auch für die polizeibeamten
es ist auch zu klären was ist die
geschichte hinter der geschichte wir
sehen hier nur eine videosequenz ein
ausschnitt aus einem gesamten handlungs
geschehen wir wissen nicht warum wurde
der kontrolliert hat ein stoppschild
überfahren oder ist ein per haftbefehl
gesucht warum wir so ein aufwand
betrieben
wir wissen auch nicht warum kam die
sparte anwendungen also ich kann das
hier nicht richtig aussehen ist es ein
rechtfertigte schusswaffen abgabe oder
vielleicht eine ungerechtfertigte kennen
wir nicht aber man sieht ja schon sehr
deutlich dass sich da eine eskalation
auf beiden seiten abspielt der mann der
gewalttätig mit seinem auto die seite
als waffe benutzt diesen
hochmotorisierten bmw dort auch andere
fahrzeuge rannte dass die verletzung der
polizeibeamten und von passanten in kauf
nimmt und die reaktion der polizisten
die tatsächlich schießen das sieht man
recht selten in deutschland dass sie
einen schuss abgeben auf dieses
fahrzeuge aus ihrer sicht wenn sie die
bilder die wir haben analysieren ist das
ein versehen gewesen in dieser
stresssituation oder ist ihnen sagen wir
mal sind ihnen handlungsanweisung
bekannt dass der polizist in der
situation so hätte reagieren müssen
möglicherweise handelt es sich hier um
eine unbeabsichtigte schussabgabe also
wir wissen ja als hoch stress lagen
verkehrskontrollen sind immer hoch
stress lagen für polizei bei der erst
recht wenn ein täter flieht bei hoch
stress waren verkrampft der körper
verkrampft die muskulatur und die sehnen
und wenn der polizeibeamte in dem moment
wo der bmw fahrer aus dem zug fährt sich
bedroht fühlt angst um sein leben hat
kann es passieren dass sich der finger
am abzug
sie schickt grund und der polizist
schießt dadurch möglicherweise sogar
zwei mal wie man hier sieht
und andererseits ist es auch
möglich dass der beamte bewusst auf das
fahrzeug geschossen hat allerdings ist
das ergebnis entsprechend das macht im
auto gar nichts aus wenn man aus dem
auto schießt das ist einfach so eine
hoch stress lage so betiteln sie je so
bezeichnen sie diese situation das
stellt sich natürlich durch den schuss
da aber auch wie die beamten sich äußern
hände hoch du [ __ ] schreien dort die
polizisten über die straße hört man
jetzt auch nicht ihr jeden tag ist das
noch mal sozusagen eine idee dafür dass
diese situation dort außer kontrolle
geraten ist ja das unterstreiche in
meinen augen jagdfieber und tunnelblick
also ein auch eine eingeschränkte
wahrnehmung normalerweise sagten
polizisten nicht du [ __ ]
das ist ganz klar das lässt darauf
schließen dass hier wirklich für den
politiker die polizeibeamten also dass
die wirklich auf 150 sind und persönlich
emotional betroffen sind und stress und
manchmal auch polizeiliche
handlungsalternativen 1
das ist einfach so und diese hoch stress
lagen kann man natürlich versuchen im
training nach zu gestalten
durch die sensibilisierung programme
kann man sowas nicht trainieren
es geht einfach nicht denn polizeibeamte
sind auch nur menschen steffen melzer
sicherheitsexperte ganz herzlichen dank
für ihre einschätzungen dieser
gefährlichen situation dort in berlin
neukölln